it's just six thirty in the morning but
not only the gulls are awake expansions
like I've been in Berlin for four years
but this is my first time on Lake
Constance ana cristina her oven from
chile was invited to this year's Nobel
laureates meeting as well it wasn't
exactly a short train ride from Berlin
but I'm very happy to be here I've ice
called me sir he has his own in the in
salalah conference venue in the center
of the old town christina is one of six
hundred young scientists attending the
meeting some visual clues are needed for
orientation my kind of Emma you can go
by the colors of the lanyards gray is
for us the unimportant little scientists
yellow like yours is for the journalists
the important people have ones that are
turquoise those are the Nobel laureates
sweet face this since the Nobel Prize
figure
and they're the reason everyone is here
they're a bit like rock stars for us
yeah the 35 Nobel laureates attending
this year are mainly these superstars in
the field of chemistry at nine o'clock
they begin to present their latest
research results this year's focus is on
green chemistry and then the man she's
been waiting to see brian kobilka the
biochemist shared the nobel prize in
2012 for his work on g protein-coupled
receptors they're involved in many
diseases and are the target of a huge
number of medicinal drugs christina is
also working on protein complexes net
successful it would be exciting to get
to know him personally or to ask him
questions just to see how it was for him
to discover these wonderful things
getting to meet real Nobel laureates up
close is one point of the meeting but
it's also about networking it's about
talking to people with whom you could
later do your doctoral work I've already
been invited to two labs so it's very
useful that way
during the lunch break there's a scrum
of undergrads and doctoral students at
the buffet a propitious moment for
Christina a unit a unit a Nobel laureate
in chemistry I'd like to ask her a
couple of things let's see if it works
is closed I'm Christina I'm also a young
researcher and it does work the
scientist Christina knows from her
textbooks are walking around here ready
and willing to chat with the young
researchers zeg Anna Frank I really like
to meet brian kobilka because he's done
something incredibly important in my
field it's every tease I'm wash sense
but first it's time to take a break
patience is a virtue that scientists
have to cultivate
you